cain internationaux pour ses propos et
s'arrête et sa rhétorique surtout après
deux affaires celle des colis piégés et
celle de la tuerie de pittsburgh 29
chefs d'accusation ont été retenus à
l'encontre de robert bauer l'auteur de
la tuerie contre la synagogue de l'arbre
de vie à pittsburgh samedi 11 morts au
dernier bilan
on a entendu dans la halle trump
s'exprimer et il a condamné l'acte est
l'oeuvre d'un cinglé guilluy délit c'est
clair net et sans appel
oui c'est un beau discours allez pour la
question en est ce que c'est la faute à
donald trump
c'est ce que pense tu en avant les
battrons de l'anti-defamation league
oui alors je pense que profond de mon
donald trump et en symptôme de quelque
chose presque autant que cet assassinat
au hockey les 294 autres cas de
de deux meurtres de masse ans aux états
unis et depuis depuis le début dès 2018
après une accalmie parce qu'il faut pas
oublier à quel point la société
américaine est violente et même les
années 60 que beaucoup regrettent il y
avait trois assassinats politiques
majeurs les docks et nady et martin
luther king il y avait le sniper fou de
de texas avec 49 morts il y avait deux
il y avait des assassinats cour a des
origines je recommande entre le récit de
leurs mandeville dans le figaro a
retrouvé qu'il est le début d'une longue
série sur justement des reportages en
pennsylvanie est il ya une ambiance de
guerre civile actuellement quand on est
simple pour ne pas aller plus loin les
50 40 30 c'était horrible il y avait une
accalmie entre les années 70 et les
années 2000 qui s'est terminée problème
ans avec la présidence d'obama et avec
le
le tea party donc tout ce qui se passe à
partir de ce moment là et évidemment je
pense que profondément les choses sont
la raison profonde c'est le la fin la
mort lente de classe moyenne aux états
unis dans les changements de modèle
économique la mondialisation et donc
qu'il re polarise est réservé une
tension puisqu'on alors évidemment et je
mets évidemment rapide je pense que
trempe n'a rien fait pour calmer les
jeux ça on peut le dire mais il n'est
pas responsable ce qu'une pierre haski
se trouve que je suis revenue hier des
états unis j'ai passé toute la semaine
dernière à new york et washington
et c'est frappant la polarisation
extrême qui a dans ce pays
à côté de ça la france c'est les
bisounours c'est et donc vous avez une
situation où est-ce que ça n'a pas
toujours été comme je savais c'est
tellement je crois pas je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
outre on parle à sa base parce que le
discours qu'on a entendu qui est
magnifique c'est parce qu'il a dit les
deux premiers jours
ses premières réactions et notamment le
soir même de la tuerie de pittsburgh
il avait un meeting électoral il a dit
qu'il avait failli annuler son meeting
parce qu'ils avaient une journée à
mauvais cheveux comme il dit cet homme
ne vois là aux yeux d'une partie de
l'amérique et sans foi ni loi et aux
yeux d'une autre partie de l'amérique
c'est l'autre partie qui est sans foi ni
loi et que et qui n'est pas crédible
il ya deux mondes totalement parallèle
qui se haïssent aujourd'hui on air on en
est à sa et donc moi je pense que donc
c'est bon gros fonds oui c'est plus
profond mais c'est c'est évident que
donald trump et le pompier pyromane dans
cette affaire il y joue en permanence à
inciter à la violence et lorsqu'elle se
produit dit on mais moi je suis pas
responsable de
de ce qui se passe on est on est etc il
n'est pas le seul à être dans ce cas là
quand même avec 100 c'est excessif qui
est une polarisation aux etats unis
c'est un sujet mais jamais donald trump
a appelé à tuer les gens à tuer des
juifs dans une dans une synagogue
je crois que la personne en l'occurrence
le reprocher d'être trop philosémite
être aux mondialistes donc il n'a pas
voulu prendre parti entre les néonazis
et les anti système beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça donc je
crois qu'on mélange qu'on mélange de
choses il ya les le problème du port
d'armes aux états unis là il a une
responsabilité mais les démocrates ont
fait vraiment la même chose avant et il
ya effectivement la question des
fractures américaine qu'on retrouve en
france de manière moins net mais avec
effectivement une amérique populaire en
amérique ouvrière une amérique du centre
qui reposait de plus en plus à
l'amérique des côtes est des grandes
métropoles et je crois qu'il ya des
responsabilités dans les deux sens si
cet électorat populaire et aussi raide
et radicalisée c'est parce qu'il a été
méprisée insulté par l'élite des côtes
depuis des années souvenez-vous de
d'hillary clinton qui parle de paniers
des déplorable et c'est pas que moi qui
le dit c'est mark lilla universitaires
américains en proche du parti démocrate
qui explique que ces étudiants on
considère que le centre de l'amérique
c'est quasiment une jungle et il n'y
aurait que s'il ya de plus dur pour eux
c'est d'aller prendre à un café tout
simplement dangereux l'un de ces états
pour parler à l'amérique populaire donc
je crois que si donald trump a peut-être
radicaliser cet électorat là de nous
c'est valable dans l'autre sens et et
voilà il ya une guerre culturelle qui
est installée et fait effectivement il
faut que ces deux amériques finissent
par se parler mais j'ai autant peur du
mouvement me to qui est une sorte de
nouveau maccarthysme et daf ministre par
exemple délivrons voilà que dès que des
saillies de mais donald trump n'a pas
fait de noir arrêté de de dieu ne se
revendiquaient pas de donald trump il
était en titre comme celle d'un fou
allez c'est marrant
fou quand les gens qui se revendiquent
de l'est l'idéologie islamiste par
exemple via une certaine gauche qui nous
explique c'est des fous et là c'est un
fou il n'y a pas parlé de donald trump
est ici on n'est pas pris d'ailleurs et
ce n'est pas pris à l'élite de la côte
est fin je vois pas pourquoi vous
politiser cette affaire là donc je pense
qu'on parle de deux choses différentes
qui est une bière cultural aux états
viennent et c'est une chose qui est un
problème de violence qui existe depuis
la naissance de ce pays avec le port
d'armes sans mener une autre mais je
crois qu'on peut pas accuser donald
trump de ski et de voilà de cette
histoire américaine violente depuis
toujours
donald trump s'est appuyé sur l'ordre
ait à la dôle l extrême droite
américaine pour se faire élire il n'a
jamais voulu d avouer ni le ku klux klan
ni les néonazis de charlottesville et il
a laissé faire toute cette frange
l'instant il ya des lobbys
pro-israéliens constructi trump et ils
sont pas dans l'eau le troll ou non mais
ça ne dit pas que il n'ya que lloyd
wright il n'aurait pas été élu s'il n'y
avait que lloyd wright qui l'avait qui
l'avaient soutenu mais il n'a jamais
prononcé une parole pour désavouer cette
frange extrémiste de plus en plus vocal
aux états unis et c'est pareil pour loeb
qui a envoyé les colis piégés qui se
baladait dans un camion avec l effigie
de donald trump est ce que ça fait de 30
pains coupable le fait non c'est l'essai
mais c'est toujours la même histoire
il s'est passé c'est pas celui qui
incitent à la violence par lorsque
lorsque donald trump dans les meetings
désigne les journalistes en disant
faites news machin etc
le jour où il y aura un journaliste qui
se fera un tabac c'est parce que ça
arrivera aux états unis il ya une telle
c'est chauffé à blanc aujourd'hui tonale
trump durable moi j'ai jamais dit qu'il
fallait leur casser la figure
c'est toujours la même histoire on peut
se retrancher en disant j'ai rien à voir
avec tout ça et bolton arrow puisqu'on
parlait lui tout à la fois mais pas sur
le dos mais ça vient d'annoncer la
véracité là bas me sens visé la même
histoire il ya
des partisans de balaruc qui ont tabassé
une femme allait défendre celui qui a
été agressé le point d'orgue
oui mais il ya une qui a acquis les dg
des gens on creuse et une croix gammée
sur le corps avec un couteau qui étaient
des partisans de bolton à rome il a dit
mais moi je peux rien faire si je ne
connais pas ces gens là on est toujours
dans cette belle histoire vous vous
créez un climat et ensuite vous n'avez
aucune responsabilité il ya un moment il
faut assumer aussi ses responsabilités
sociales le dit en réponse à la question
twitter nancy le temps tous les jours
sur twitter en prenant les théories du
complot et en montant régulièrement
trump attise la haine et la violence bch
le dis en plus du tram bashing on ne
peut pas en faire le bouc émissaire
nicole nous dit les démocrates ont
décidé que trump était le diable et tout
ce qui arrive aux états unis est de sa
faute
on continuera bien sûr d'en parler les
scientifiques c'est le diable a vu
comment il traite la science en
continuant à en parler et justement d'en
faire une émission sur le sur les
accords de paris en attendant je voulais
vous poser une dernière question c'est
si vous regrettez les années gildas
comment réussir à la tamise